hey guys welcome back to New Rockstar's
black panther wakanda forever is
officially out yes come out now and
we've got some theories sure enough to
make your head spin like that helicopter
that no more took down seriously how
metal was uh I only hope they come into
the MCU because we're going to
helicopter over my head uh this this
isn't the break room this isn't
something else this isn't talking
dragons you guys this is Rogue Theory
the wildest theories for the nerdy
titles we love and spoiler alert we will
be talking about Black Panther wakanda
forever so consider this your spoiler
warning I'm not giving you another one
just just just be prepared this this
comes out tomorrow so you have time
tomorrow Saturday I'm Jessica Clemens
and I'm hosting today's Rogue Theory
because I deserve to to make sure
everyone go sees black panther I don't
know I just deserve this uh with me
today is Whitney van laningham hi hi um
can I sing you just a really quick song
that I wrote yeah go ahead okay it goes
when the guy from the sea shows the land
no mercy that's nomore
I'm here for that I signed that green
lit uh Capitol Records get on it Tom
Michaelson so I would do the wakanda
forever but maybe I need to do the
hadouken yeah welcome everyone thank you
very much rise to low cost
and Zach Huddleston hey I'm Zach don't
follow me on Twitter I haven't tweeted
in three years
perfect normally for rogue Theory we
always give like a little bit of like a
description of who everybody is but for
black panther wakanda forever I was like
I don't think there's one I can come up
with for you guys so I'm just gonna
leave them at their names you totally
could have been like and Whitney who
also listens to can't stop by the Red
Hot Chili Peppers when she jogs because
she's white oh I could have done that
but then these two I would have been
left alone with I was like because I was
like thinking I was like oh maybe I'll
make them MIT profession
I'm your favorite colonizer
okay let's do that okay let's do that we
got it all right everyone is better than
me so wakanda forever had so many
lingering details so many open doors for
phase five and six and you know here are
new rock stars we can make endless
theories on all of them so one of those
Theory branches I'd like to explore and
get into is with my biggest Theory and
my also biggest surprise for what kind
of forever is that now ex-wife to
Everett Everett Ross Valentina Allegra
de Fontaine who is now allegedly the CIA
director which is dangerous
um which leads us to our first topic
today why Valentina wants that vibranium
because in the movie that was one of the
biggest shocks for me is a figuring out
that she was once married to Everett
Ross but B how much she impacted the
whole search for the vibranium I think
ultimately she was the one that was in
charge of making sure they get out in
the Atlantic I think her planting those
beads for Everett Ross was also just
like I need to get that vibranium I need
to get into wakanda I need to learn what
he knows so I can get in there just to
get brainium so what I think this leads
to is the search for the vibranium in
the Atlantic Ocean was all overseen by
Valentina Allegra Fontaine so I think
Val is trying to start a vibranium sort
of War which we already kind of see in
the movie where like we have the
beginning with the French kind of uh
having their own people go into the
um base of the wakandans to try stealing
vibranium but I think it's also
ultimately just like that was a big
thing that we should think about is the
fact that you can't pick it up on like
any metal detectors and it's just
durable so I think she's trying to get
um Riri William's suit and I think she's
trying to get the vibranium so she can
use some sort of Star Technology and
create the most indestructible weapon
for the Thunderbolts and I think this
can also go across iron uh ironheart and
armor Wars because I don't think
Valentina is done with Riri Williams I
think she's going to keep approaching
her I think her it was a smart move
being like hey I'm not going to steal
from the child directly I'm gonna steal
from the professor but now it's clear
that she she can do it all on her own so
why not try to approach her and get her
in on your deal so I think Val will be
stretching this long game over ironheart
armor war is when she's stealing roady's
machine and using iron hearts two uh
Thunderbolts where they're like
hopefully we have an Iron Man vibranium
suit which is stronger than the Hulk
which is stronger than Abomination so
you wouldn't need to grab those giant
big people for that team wow that is uh
dude that is not just a theory for
wakanda forever that's one for the next
five Marvel movies and shows man wow I
think it's amazing but yeah I don't
think people overlooked it more so I
just think that Val is dangerous and I
think we get a bigger picture of that
today where it's like I can run circles
around any person here like I don't care
I'm the director of whatever it is and
so I think her having that position
where she can control a fleet of like
our prize soldiers to go get wakandan
vibranium is so dangerous to what end
what does she want I think I think she
just wants to make that Iron Man suit I
think she wants to make that suit and
she wants to make that tool but to do
what oh just to fight in the
Thunderbolts well because what did she
want out of the Thunderbolt I don't well
I my pitch is for getting it for the
Thunderbolts not what the Thunderbolts
are doing well why do the superpowers
want all this all the be the strongest
anyway you know it's like a nuclear
deterrent you want to be the strongest
you want to be the world leader maybe
having a you know a suit of vibranium or
Iron Man for the US military is the way
to go but does it seem like she's like
some kind of super patriot who wants
American dominance to me all of her
actions have always felt like she's an
independent operator well she said she's
out for herself she said in Black
Panther wakanda forever remember when he
was like do you imagine what would
happen if we got a hold of vibranium and
she's like I dream of it so I think she
still is like I want to be the most
strongest Nation they shouldn't be the
strongest nation and having the
Thunderbolts as your like your army and
being like that's like what Thunderball
Ross did with the Avengers he's like I
own them but it's like I own the
Thunderbolts which I are way more
smarter and tactical in my opinion I'm
sorry granted that you know the granted
that uh you know Thunderbolts is really
far away
um and this may not pan out if Val's
going to be in that but let's not forget
that she could be a squirrel like
speaking to Zach exactly I mean maybe
that I think Everett Ross was
unknowingly married to his scroll oh
yeah
that's why they got divorced because uh
his like real wife was great and then he
and she yeah a [ __ ]
you changed on me literally I had like a
long-term theory that and I think a lot
of people probably online agree with
this that there's a possibility that
Everett Ross is Thaddeus Ross's son and
when he was married to Allegra or to Val
Thaddeus uh Thunderbolt Ross was
probably more aligned with Val's Mission
and probably we'll see in the future if
that is true they'll be working closer
together and then we just have Everett
Ross who is now a stowaway in wakanda
um and against them he'll be the second
white wolf I
he's not as nuts as Bucky but you know
that's funny that kind of leads into
something else I was thinking about
which is
um well it's a very small part of that
but I think she would use the vibranium
to get a shield for John Walker a
vibranium US agency because because you
know looking at the light
of that show oh sorry
but because that was
that they're gonna have to I assume
they're gonna bring up is because he's
U.S agent always has his version of The
Shield so now they can have a vibrating
shield for him you know if red Guardians
on it she could make a vibrating Shield
there's a lot of Shield people on the
Thunderbolts that need weapons that
makes more sense I thought they were
going to just follow the same like
mapping of the Avengers and just make an
Iron Man like just be like okay hey
Crimson Dynamo maybe he's coming up
maybe maybe they're gonna maybe this and
have him all this is to say she did not
leave this movie with any vibranium
but she does know it's in the ocean and
it's just but then it's also like she
doesn't know that just oh well yeah she
doesn't know the tolokans exist so it's
like but she knows there's a third party
could you imagine if she sends the
Thunderbolts to the ocean and the
thunderbols just easily get picked off
and it's like great there goes ghosts
one of the scariest moments in my
opinion was when he was like I have as
many like Fighters as the blades of
grass in the field and I was just like
oh that's like actually terrifying they
had a great liners of house how did they
make green short shorts and wings on
your ankles badass I just I just
couldn't 400 year olds uh green short
shirts by the way yeah yeah and now I
was just thinking this nemour is besides
the asgardians now that especially since
uh the Mandarin is dead now more the
oldest person on Earth yeah every person
is personhood whatever he's mutant he's
something else but he's still like half
human
I I I'm like but as like a half human
being it's like he's the oldest yeah
right because the eternals are still
kind of like robots and how many
internals are left on on the planet
right now right ultimately my theory is
that I think this is gonna I mean I
think the movie started with a vibranium
War we already saw it that every other
country was like give me that damn
vibranium but I think uh it's not over
for Val and Val's like I'm gonna get my
hands on that damn belt how do you think
she does that I
I hate to say it but I think she's gonna
send the Thunderbolts and they're gonna
get killed by those mermaids she's
really smart and she's very sneaky and
she's very and I love how calculated Val
is but like she doesn't have any other
option other than sending America after
the wakandans which is a bad idea we'd
lose so I think she's like I have a
special team that I think we should send
in and it's like we're gonna see the
Thunderbolts go against the will condens
and talocon which is not a good idea I'm
just imagining them showing up like all
badass the Thunderbolts and then the
then the telecon's been like oh and then
they just don't throw themselves off
cliffs because nobody knows about that
dude I mean kill yourself how many
weapons died because of a little song
there was just a little jingle playing
games
[Music]
I've heard the 1-800 seven or the 1877
cars for kid commercial too many times
I'm gonna kill myself now but that was a
really like yeah powerful weapon they
got those like what are the priestesses
maybe because only certain ones can do
it otherwise wouldn't all of them do it
I think all of them can do oh I think
they can all do it I think they got it
with their powers so that is my theory
that is my theory I think it's gonna
start a vibranium War I think it's going
to be hosted by Val and she's gonna lose
but we also I think we still have to
wait until over like even phase five to
phase six I think it would be the
beginning of say six where she actually
like initiates it because I think she's
gonna exhaust all of her options before
she jumps right into it because Val's
not an idiot uh so that's my theory
do you guys think it's rogus bogus or
togus every what's the middle one oh yes
oh yes and I invented the yogurt I love
this I think it's great because it
definitely makes a lot of sense with
what we've just seen and it makes sense
for where they could go with it and in
terms of Val having a team with guys
that need vibranium weapons and maybe
wanting to get America to have vibranium
uh you know tools and and more and you
know weapons again I think that this
might even be setting up black panther
three because black panther three is not
going to be coming out for a while too
and just like you said after phase six
you know this could be about the world
coming after wakanda is what I was
imagining is that now you know we've had
this we've and and now they might need
to actually team up with talocon like
yeah which was like Hey when they're
when they need us they're going to come
for us and guess what that's when we'll
be able to do what we want to do and
then it'll be kind of like a World War
vibranium World War almost really okay
join Theory uh yeah well they go hand in
hand
was it I'm gonna go rogus because
literally because the I was going to say
the exact same thing as you the I dream
of it yeah that's where I was like okay
she's not gonna stop being up to
something anytime soon she's a mad
scientist she sure is I'm gonna as
somebody who shows up on Rogue Theory
once a year or less I'm gonna go bogus
oh I filmed it I knew it here's my thing
I want what's the evidence
other than like her being like searching
for it well because my thing is like
obviously she wants power she wants to
accumulate super powered individuals for
Thunderbolts but like she has said so
little she's a master spy right there's
only hints of manipulation most of her
screen time in wakanda forever was spent
with double entender's with her
ex-husband you know what I mean and No
No Agenda has been laid out even in the
little bits we've seen her with the
Elena and Johnny mayonnaise and whatever
right like she's putting together a team
for I I just haven't seen enough on
screen to tell me what is she really
after and that's why I was kind of
pressing you earlier what's her end game
she wants a team for what right like I
haven't heard her like say like super
patriotic stuff like the U.S needs to be
a superpower
old is that well and I haven't heard
that either though that's the only
problem like that's the default super
villain
series which you know hey yes hey hey if
me and Zach are on Rogue Theory and it
was hosted by Mt it would be a lot of
boguses oh my God it's all it's all
about girls
like that's still two out of three yeah
I agree with it I agree with it it is it
is a very Rogue Theory because we do not
have evidence all the only evidence we
have is I dream of it and that's the
part where it stuck to me I was like
about she's not just dreaming about
having a vibranium vibrator baby no
she's dreaming no she actually wants to
make it in the world for herself or she
wants to make all vibrating coins and
then Scrooge mcducket and swim and
that's her ultimate goal just to swim
right here all this vibration
no not at all oh my God okay so up next
Zach has his own Rogue black I know and
I've now set the table for people online
here we go really come from let me
practice let me practice but yeah let me
let me get this okay let me make sure my
thumb pointing down and aggressive
enough uh be sure to head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com where you can pick up
some awesome new rockstars merch
including our newest latest Obsession
shirt based on black panther wakanda
Forever This is a limited edition shirt
so be sure to grab it while you can
check out all of our awesome merch
options over at New rockstarsmerge.com
and we also want to thank our partners
at baluchu for sponsoring Rogue Theory
this week Bluetooth can help give you
that extra bit of confidence when it
matters the most and we know it always
matters most blue chew is a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
but in a chewable tablet so you don't
have to swallow anymore you just chew it
and add a fraction of the cost you can
take them anytime day or night morning
evening Twilight time so you can plan
ahead or be ready whenever your
opportunity arises and let me tell you
it will arise the process is simple sign
up at bluetooth.com consult with one of
their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
it's all done online so no visits to the
doctor's office no awkward conversations
I hate talking to doctors I'm always
awkward I always look to my mom I'm 28
years old and no waiting in line at a
pharmacy Bluetooth tablets are made in
the USA and prepared and shipped direct
to your door in a discreet package so no
one will know and we've got a special
deal for you first-time listeners or
last time listeners nope not last time
all the time listeners
try our promo code Rogue at checkout
just pay five dollars shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code Rogue to
receive your first month for free visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank Bluetooth for sponsoring this
podcast hey thank you to butcher also
blue I mean we're kind of forever
featured a lot of Blue Characters
I don't know that we saw any of them
chewing but
um
there are a lot of like seaweed
cultivation that I appreciated yeah you
didn't get a boner though when no more
what oh God it's my favorite part when
umbaku just comes up and tries to like
deck him from behind and he doesn't even
flinch
when he punches through the armor I was
like I thought he I thought he grabs his
heart out like straight up we got the
super slo-mo like uh Mortal Kombat kill
screen x-ray fatalities
like that was like I was like this man
I've ever seen in my life
he's gonna be a problem but also we want
to shout out our our second uh and final
uh sponsor for today's show
um and this I'm actually rocking the
t-shirt that they sent along with this
product and we've got the actual
physical products here our friends over
at iconic cocktail company
um we actually I I spoke with the CEO of
this company Matt shout out he's a fan
of new rockstars watches our content
hopefully he's watching Rogue Theory
today but um uh if you like a an adult
libation every once one I gotta say
Daddy every once in a while I just tuck
it in for the evening appreciates a
little night cap okay and you know
sometimes you could crack open a beer or
get a glass of wine but if you're at
home and you just want to make yourself
a nice little cocktail these things are
awesome they have a bunch of different
flavors these are these are the two I've
tried cranberry Thyme and spiced honey
this spiced honey is very nice it's got
like Szechuan peppercorns in it so it's
got like a little uh I don't know it
lights up the mouth
this is like really nice with bourbon or
whiskey or or different they have
different uh recipes for other kinds of
uh alcohols whatever you want to try uh
iconic cocktail uh makes all natural
mixers and sodas for cocktails all their
products are made with real ingredients
by real bartenders for really easy to
make drinks they're the ideal ingredient
for the perfect cocktail or mocktail and
one thing I wanted to point out we are
recording this in the morning okay it
would be inappropriate to be drinking
alcohol at this time of day while at
work but you can mix these with just
like soda water and you get yourself a
little mocktail or maybe you got people
in your family or in your household that
don't drink alcohol they can still enjoy
a little bit straight too yes
um straight out of
iconic cocktail.com over there it's
loaded with easy to search recipes as
well as tips and tricks to add a little
Spirit to your home bar you can follow
their simple method for three-step
cocktails or explore over 150 unique
recipes uh we tried um their Copper
State Mule cocktail uh with the Ginga
ginger syrup I'm Ginger Ginger I think
it's Ginger and ginger uh and again I've
really enjoyed the um the spiced honey
in Suburban ooh yes nice way to check in
for the evening put on some Samurai Jack
uh
yes just let the day float away you know
what I mean
um so discover some new cocktails for
yourself and add a little Spirit to your
next drink by visiting iconic
cocktail.com and use our promo code new
rockstars to get 20 off your order again
that's iconic cocktail.com for recipes
education and more and use promo code
new rockstars for 20 off thank you to
iconic cocktails perfect you guys up
next don't don't don't don't warm up
those boguses don't warm up those
Augustus only the rogus is you guys uh
it's time for our second Rogue Theory
today and for that I'm going to pass the
mic to Zach thank you thank you and
again I've set the stage for a lot of
stuff and I understand that that's the
Trap well like I I think I loved love
loved this movie and and like I found
like as much as they built a wakanda in
that first film that was so like fully
realized and engrossing and beautiful
and like felt real I thought they did
the same thing with telecon in this film
right like even just the fact that they
said like capital city City
for that say oh there's a lot of other
cities
like this is a full like we got a little
glimpse of the agriculture at the sports
they play you know like the market yeah
everything there
um and so and and I love even the like
uh the way uh no more kind of like
described his relationship with his
people that he's been preparing them for
hundreds of years for war with the
surface right that he's his brain was so
shaped by his experience with those like
Spanish uh colonizers back in the day
and what they did to his mother's
Homeland so that like that is formed as
a world view and that has influenced
this whole society and so I I was really
struck in what led to my theory that
final scene we see of him and I believe
it's nomura right like she comes into
his cave as he's you know putting the
the newest on the Memoir uh graphic or
whatever
every 57 year old
does because like think about it his
when he was like a little kid his mom
had fully aged oh yeah so that was like
a 57 year old kid that was wild yeah
yeah he was yeah looked 11 or whatever
also kudos to the 11 year old actor
I don't even have any lines but just
like the pathos that he showed in his
facial acting and like the presence he
he had again wearing green short shorts
but still like like making you feel in
that moment they definitely casted like
the angriest looking child yes and it
was perfect those eyebrows were arched
for anger yeah yes but so that the final
scene we see with no more while he's
he's finishing his his wall graphic
novel and um the more it comes in and
she's like you bent the knee to wakanda
you've literally told us all of our
entire history as a people that like we
are the best like we will destroy the
world we will bring the surface people
to their knees and you bend the knee to
one country right and so and you know he
has a good reasoning there like oh they
need an ally we'll be their only Ally
they'll turn to us the next time they
get in trouble sure but here's what I
think my my rogue Theory the next time
we see no more
the telecons will have turned on him and
he will be an outcast of his own people
he will no longer be the the leader of
telecon and uh he will be forced in fact
it's not it's not wakanda that's going
to need him as an ally it's him that's
going to need wakanda okay okay and
here's my reasoning again he's this
weird he's separate from all of his
people too right he's the only not Blue
Dude down there right and he's kind of
this like God leader character right
right as Winston do as Winston
he took that he ate it up he's like
ready for this here one take yeah as my
ringtone
but like you know and so he's he's built
up this Mythos of like both he is a god
figure to these people he's made himself
their God they've made him their God
right like and like they're this like
Warrior culture and then he gets beat up
he loses right like that like totally
that's that's like uh you know Jesus is
coming down and he can't turn into line
and everything yeah Jesus gets as
Whiplash says when you see God bleed
people cease to believe in him and they
right he's the serpent God he's not the
king he's not their leader they
literally think of him as a God yeah he
bent the knee yeah and so much of his
power is tied up in this this god-like
uh stature in their mind and so now that
that's gone right like I think that
people are gonna turn on him because
again in the comics characters like uh
atuma yeah are are adversaries they're
not on his side right like and and kind
of like and I totally understand this
movie had so much work to do so much to
explain right they couldn't get into the
Nuance of tolokan culture and the sex
and stuff like that that s-e-c-t-s nut
yes
the divisions and whatever right right
well and kind of like it also might have
felt too repetitive with the Aquaman
movie right which really got into like
all the divisions the different groups
of people that exist in the ocean but
it's the same in in Atlantis in the
comics right and like there are all
these uh warlord crying and like uh um
also like piranha and there's all these
great like villains that are other
talukkans that like fight or have been
Outcast and they have their own bands of
people that come and come for Namor and
there's like periods when like not more
leaves the the underwater Kingdom and
like different people take over then he
tries to come back and there's battles
and stuff like that so I think the
people will turn on him I think atuma
nomura will meet other badass telecons
that are gonna like be like we thought
this dude was God and he's he's not he
got beat up on a beach you know what I
mean like you guys
he's down to three Wings
salamander Jessica the tail will go back
you just gotta give it like three months
so two things one uh for hundreds and
hundreds of years he's been protecting
those people and cultivating that world
underneath you think that they would
outweigh that one time to these 100s
sometimes well that that's a great point
but like think about Black Panther one
the Black Panther had been protecting
wakanda for since the beginning of their
country and they turned on him
that's a title
there's a title as opposed to Navarre is
like the one
but more so right like uh Black Panther
was kind of dethroned even though the
t'challa Black Panther was just as
powerful as every black panther that had
ever come before he had the heart-shaped
herb and a better suit than they
probably had in the 30s or whatever
right and yet in that this number has
been proven to be less powerful than
they thought he was the only argument I
would say to that is like the people in
telecon have lived so much longer than
the people of wakanda so it's like they
can cultivate trust much longer than the
people of wakanda could and since
they're in different regions because we
haven't seen the different regions of
talocon of the talk on people that I I
think that like the Jabari of course
have different views than the other
tribes because they're like we're in the
freaking mountains so it's like until we
see those other uh talokins maybe then
that's when like they can like actually
be like this guy sucks
but I I just I feel like nomura and
atuma hold such regard to him because he
still is also like this is also just me
thinking I wouldn't go up against the
strongest one of us any is technically
stronger than a Tuma nomura so it's like
he can throw a helicopter he's known to
be stronger than Thor and the Hulk I
would I'd be like yeah whatever he says
but then again as we found at the end
you know if he just if he ends up going
to Vegas he's going to be he's gonna be
tapped down
he can't fight you in Scottsdale
but it's also like how much of the world
it's more water than land right so it's
like it's gonna be hard for us even at
the desert it was like here's water you
can just go to it and that that is sea
water sorry oh yeah well I mean in
theory the the wakanda is not on the sea
so like the body of water they said
something like he swam 2000 kilometers
or something like that like like he came
up through a river well and another
thing I think would be interesting like
we see the more do like the most awesome
stuff out of water right that's when
he's grabbing helicopters that's when
he's like beating up in boxes
because helicopters weren't under the
water Zach
oh that's true that'd be that'd be a
submarine but
uh
well but I think what's interesting is
like he's definitely more powerful
they're still badass they're still super
strong a tumor on that bridge is beating
the hell out of it right she was the
only one that took out the sound the
booming sound system that was blaring
their ears yeah she was the only one
that could swim through the sound yes
yeah so like nomura natuma particularly
or powerful but I wonder right like
they're still not as powerful as him
outside of water they can't fly and like
do some stuff like that but like I
wonder actually underwater if the power
levels are a little bit more I mean the
flying doesn't help you underwater right
like unless the wings make you swim
faster they did mention when they were
shooting at him
um that they were like he's much like
faster underwater than he is above water
uh because they're trying to shoot him
with that gun and he was straight up he
was a missile but I do like to say with
me negging all these things or being
negative to all these things I do like
the theory that because it's like if he
messes up again I would definitely be
like okay I'm not fine with you anymore
because and that's and it's like a 50 50
chance so it's like if he loses again
and also not to be horrible it is kind
of true but he literally was like the
most strongest person on the surface
world is shuri and it's like you don't
know the recipe
yeah other people you're strong don't
get me wrong but also can you imagine
going against her and the Hulk and Thor
and I I just like speculating and also I
so loved like that character that
performance Tina Huerta is so good right
and like there's so much
it has a totally different vibe than all
the other Marvel characters we've met
like it's kind of a little Sly and again
no more name or in the comics right is
like one of the most famous anti-heroes
right like from the jump he's been like
quasi-villain like sometimes he's a good
guy hey if if Atlantis and the rest of
the world are aligned I'll defend the
world yeah but if it's ever Atlantis the
rest of the world the rest of the
world's gonna pay it right like and I
love that so like just to see him again
if he gets Outcast from his his people
and he's forced to kind of be on the the
surface world you know we'll get him
like a wetsuit or something like that so
he's cool he's chill he's chilling New
York or whatever yeah yeah we could get
like a a pickup truck hot tub or
something like that that he can cruise
around
assistant who walks around it with a
super soaker
but like can you imagine him
can you imagine him on a thunderbolt can
you imagine him on a some other version
of an Avengers right I think no and I
think that's why they made him so
aligned with his people and Amora and
atuma it's like if he was on a team
which I don't think he can work on a
team unless it's his people it would
just be disastrous in a good way like it
would be they would be murdering people
like he would just be he would be
murking everybody and I think and also
like you could also see because again
he's 400 years old he's been living in
the ocean this entire time like he has a
little bit of that like first Thor movie
Fish Out of Water pardon the pun
um right where it's like he's like Xbox
you know what I mean like yeah
you know he reminds me of which is if
you didn't watch House of the Dragons he
reminds me of vagar where it's just like
I'm old and I don't really care but I
just want to protect myself and what I
have so it's like I'm just gonna destroy
anyone in my way as long as they're in
my way it's like when Bucky tried to
date and it was just like oh you can't
man you can't do it you're crazy man if
I say a random combination of code you
come back
there's no Tinder account for like 100
year old dudes who want maybe maybe
underwater there is we don't know
vibranium like I just I just want I
still want no more to join like
Thunderbolts Avengers whatever and just
like you know they're out fighting and
then they're like you know they're doing
like Battle of New York style fight and
then he looks over and he sees a sushi
restaurant and he's like oh hell no
oh absolutely oh could you imagine if he
ran into
um if he ran into uh Captain America or
Sam Wilson and they're fishing
picks up that [ __ ] and they're like we
just got alone on it exactly he's gonna
just cut it in half with his legs
oh my gosh let's rate Zacks let's rate
Zach's oh let's start let's start with
Utah you know I don't usually thumbs
down to theory that often and I'm not
starting today
because you're exactly right atuma is a
villain in the comics you know and and
there's a lot more to this world and
they were not happy that he bent the
knee and that would be really good that
would be a really good way also to get
him out of talocon and get him onto the
surface so that he can join the rest of
the MCU it's kind of hard for him to be
part of the MCU if he's underwater and
everybody's above land yeah but you know
like you know if he's going to be with
the Thunderbolts instead of them you
know going swimming they could bring him
out so he can like you know skate around
sorry I love Nice Guy Tom for the first
time second I just want to throw in one
other quick thing like at the end when
shuri and Namor roll in on the on the
plane are like hey guys quit fighting
right the telokans are winning yeah
they've got like they've got like a
little circle of wakanda
you're in our ocean we're about to we've
got thousands of us we're about to whip
you and like we saw like a smile on the
face of embaku and a koi or what hey yay
they're like we didn't see any to Logan
Smiles you know they were like oh good
good also it's like they're they
regenerate they can come back uh the
wakandans cannot when they started
fighting I was like did you guys not
listen to Okoye when she was like I
stabbed three of them and they came back
a little bit more because yeah that's a
that's a huge power of theirs that they
we just kind of glossed over when he
brought this up I talked about it in my
review the fact that they had like less
than two years to get this all out after
everything happened there's stuff that
is not it's not willing it doesn't make
or break the movie for me but it's like
they couldn't explore now the reason why
I bring it up is just a real quick side
time and I actually had a little Theory
I don't even I can't don't think I can
even take credit for it I heard it
somewhere else I'm sure it was too good
it's too good I thought I thought that
this was going to be a way to bring
hillbunker back they threw him in the
ocean like he wanted I thought they were
gonna fight his body no I thought they
were gonna find the uh the title cons
were gonna find his body bring him back
and then he would somehow be involved
now and and when I saw when I saw them
come back to life guys I was like oh
[ __ ] they're doing it they're doing it
and then but then I saw him in the
astral plane I was like oh
yeah well I thought that was gonna be
their way to bring it back and then
maybe if not in the this movie five
movies down the line kill Margaret could
get a Redemption Arc like Loki maybe and
become a black panther for real I don't
know that's just what I wouldn't be
surprised after all that time from when
his mom first and like ingested the
plant if they have created something
that's like yeah we can just give it to
the dead and they can revive with the
same to Logan he was dying maybe he
wasn't dead yeah and there is some
nuancy right because they they also
killed the tiloken when when she shoots
uh when uh um uh Lupita miyaga I always
forget that character's name
she kills the woman in the cave right
and they're like oh this is gonna be bad
so it's like we know they can die AI but
we also know that like getting stabbed
with a vibranium spear does not kill
that right it's yeah okay keep that
keep that it could also be the Warriors
and that's why it's like these are the
people that stay and gather where the
warrior where are the fighters the ones
that can regenerate yeah uh which again
we didn't have time to explore and we
could explore one thing I just thought
of is what if it's vibrating related
because the vibranium sword somehow they
they can counteract vibranium but Sonic
weapon that's just nothing maybe that's
why she's like oh can you save me really
I can't yes because she was gonna help
her with the akoi or the beads and then
she was like oh that's right we'll get
in this is another rope theory yes
let's keep it on uh I'm giving that a
rogus because I generally liked it and
that came with evidence which I did not
[Laughter]
dude definitely Rogas I also thought
that because like you already said it's
just you can't come back from it after
you have convinced an entire people
thousands and thousands and thousands of
people across and like you also said
that's just the capital that's just the
capital they could be all over the
goddamn ocean floor and all of those
people for so many years kind of
basically wasted their time believing
that this dude was just gonna like lay
Siege to anyone and now they have to
deal with the fact that he's actually
like I don't know like he's making
reasonable decisions based on new
information
I disagree with it still yeah
it's like he's learning what he's
learning he has empathy he's growing as
a person like yeah but I can see why
everyone else would be like when you
[ __ ] wasted our time you piece of
[ __ ] no and then they overthrow him they
try to make him into Sushi ugh can't
wait
so that's three do you give yourself a
rocus
I didn't even give myself away
you know what after you came at me and
maybe I deserve a bogus so I got two
books okay no no I I understand my flaw
um you guys it's time for a real
question now that Ruby Williams has
officially joined the MCU as the power
suited iron heart it's your turn what
would be the name your name as an
armored Mech to wearer in the MCU and
this better be good what a great place I
know think on it for a minute okay yeah
okay
um
I can't think of one
okay so like having a metal pun or
something like that would be helpful if
if that's um I got mine I'd be Tom
tanium
I love that that's a good one it's not
dontania man that way if someone takes
up the mantle after me let's say Tommy
Bechtel who's the better Tom obviously
if he wanted he could also be a
tomtanium
yeah
tomasina Thomasina
uh I'm gonna be you know what here's
here's my thing I am a physically weak
person okay I I do not have a strong
Constitution I would fold Under Pressure
don't handle stress well so like I think
I would want to be tin can Sam
okay it would be like not bulletproof
you know what I mean a strong wind would
probably ripping arm off
Route and I'm going to be called a
Steely can and I was also a can but I
only play Steely Dan yes
no metal sounds like the name Whitney
I'm having a heart nothing sounds like
Jessica that's why I want to stealy cam
um Steely can oh
[Applause]
yeah
I also do Whitney Whitney vibrating oh
there it is oh that's the strongest of
all
I'm that one to Whitney because yeah
I struggled really hard
second place definitely goes the same
but titanium
you guys uh as Rogue theory is uh
everybody is a winner everybody wins
except for me that's it for this episode
of Rogue Theory thanks to our guest Tom
Michaelson Winnie van landingham and
Zach Huddleston support our Channel by
checking out all our awesome merch over
at New rockstarsmerch.com follow me at
Lulu underscore Clemens follow new
rockstars on all social media platforms
and be sure to subscribe to our channel
here on YouTube see you next time
[Music]